so adobe conducted a study of over 9 000
content creators and the findings are
pretty surprising we actually learn
about
creator mental health we learn about
some tips for starting or growing as a
content creator right now uh and there's
some actually shocking insights in this
report and so i'm excited to dive into
these um but if you're just jumping on
or watching the replay smash the like
button my name is sean cannell rhymes
with youtube channel and i just had my
second boy john steven cannell in fact
he's literally in a uh front pack right
now and who knows how good this stream
is going to go if he kind of you know
wakes up then it'll be over but in the
meantime here we are multitasking and
shout out to uh parent life uh and i'm
excited to get into this study and so
this is talking about uh creators in the
creator economy this was done by adobe
i'll make sure that this is linked up in
the description down below um and this
is pretty crazy because they discovered
that 165 million creators have started
since 2020 so i'm going to be unpacking
some of the highlights from this and
then i have six tips for you and kind of
some like summary insights but uh
this might be kind of discouraging
that's a lot of people jumping into the
crater economy but here's what's uh the
good news about that is yes i believe
competition is rising more people than
ever before want to do this but also
consumption is rising and what we're
going to discover later is that actually
the creator economy is very lucrative
there's a lot of money and a lot of
money to be made and so you know how
many coffee shops are there how many
restaurants are there if there's people
who eat food there's an opportunity to
start a restaurant if there's people who
drink coffee there's an opportunity to
start a coffee shop if there's people
who consume content there's an
opportunity to be a content creator and
i think that's why so many people are
joining now
in since 2020 the creator economy has
grown exponentially and over one in two
creators have began posting in just the
last two years now what's kind of crazy
about this study is it is global and so
it's 9 000 creators surveyed it was a
like weighted really well done
scientific study um or you know
research-based study and so it's
covering brazil and south carol uh korea
spain france have been showing
significant jumps in new creators and
let me know where you're watching from
are you here in the u.s canada australia
or are you somewhere else in the world i
think
us understanding that the crater economy
is a global opportunity
and this study really reveals that
now one of the things that was
surprising to me is they kind of drew a
distinction between a creator versus an
influencer and so
um
i often would think what's the
difference and here's kind of how they
defined it a lot of less people
identified as influencers more as
creators and so this is how they broke
up the audiences of this survey
creators
were adults over the age of 18 and they
were participating in creative
activities like photography creative
writing nft creation
and they post share and promote their
work from these online online activities
and
here's my summary of that creators are
somebody that's maybe doing something
else their photo their photographer
videographer you know creative writing
and then they're starting a youtube
channel to promote their work okay so
then they define influencers differently
those are content creators who have
uh 5 000 followers on their main social
channel and earn money directly through
posting social media content
so an influencer is somebody right who
just is earning money
through probably adsense and being
supported by their community and a
creator this is their survey
is more defined as
someone who has some other kind of
income stream some other kind of
business model and what we saw here was
that the majority of people
that are joining the creator economy
fall into this creator category not this
influencer category maybe how do you
think of influencers do you like the
term influencer you know what i mean you
think of influencers as somebody who
like literally just selfies themself and
like their channel is all about just
them that's fine but that's the smaller
segment
furthermore
they also have this category of business
owners which is content creators who own
a business which includes being a
contractor or a freelancer that sells or
makes money from creating
creative content shared online and we
impact a lot of people here in the think
media podcast as a lot of our community
you know you got your real estate agent
a loan officer a personal trainer you
have some kind of other business you're
like let me start using youtube content
creating youtube content let me start
creating social media content
to
get more leads customers and sales in my
business and then they also broke out
gen z just as its own category and
social cause creators for those who are
trying to advance causes and issues
online and so again
it's just interesting what the
difference between creator and
influencer here and i'm curious do you
associate a difference with those two
do you define a creator different do you
define an influencer different and i'm
actually curious how do you identify
would you call yourself a youtuber a
full you know a content creator an
influencer
or something else like when you think
about your approach right at this moment
to
being a content creator and being a part
of the creative you know entrepreneur
small business owner and are you you
know author or speaker who creates
content business owner who creates
content let me know
so what they discovered was that
influencers are not as popular as they
may seem only about 14 of creators are
influencers
and i know this term gets mixed up right
you know uh i think about like rene
burchard has a conference called
influencers and he defines the term as
author speaker coach online marketer
consultant that's kind of in this new
world who's influencing culture he would
say
that you know mark twain was an
influencer he'd be right you know that
maya angelou was an influencer so that's
like one term i know that when we think
influencers though we think of like
you know somebody that's literally just
traveling to exotic destinations and
taking selfies i'm just kind of curious
so
um
next
there are benefits to living in crater
hot spots markets with overall higher
concentrations of craters tend to have
more happy craters who create more and
note
locational creativity advantages the us
brazil spain australia and the uk
consistently stand out for these factors
what's the takeaway here one of the
findings was location matters in real
estate they say location location
location and i think this is an
important insight now you may feel
locked down or of course your priorities
may be family
you know like mine obviously i have
literally a a one week old boy
a front pack this is the most ridiculous
stream i've ever done but you know you
might have not that there has to be a
conflict between family and content
creation clearly you can integrate
things
but i think the unlock here for me is
that
there is a benefit
to being in a place where there's a
concentration of other creators or the
ability to collab the ability to
have synergy and it probably depends on
the type of content you're creating i
just know this when i was in a small
town i grew up in arlington and then
marysville washington there was nowhere
near the amount of opportunity to grow
what is now our business than there is
here in las vegas i live in las vegas
now
creators are constantly coming here
events are constantly here there's all
types of people to interview collaborate
with i can fly to 45 minutes to orange
county i can fly to utah really quick or
drive up to st george i can get to
arizona really quick so being in a hub
i've really experienced this
idea that location matters obviously la
is a place where it's definitely a
creator hub
and then on the flip side now we spend
part time in seattle
and we're blessed as our businesses have
grown to uh to be able to have family
about six months of the year where we're
around grandparents
all summer long we're out of the vegas
heat the punch line is just this unlock
that this could be something for you to
consider that sometimes when you have a
vision or you want something to happen
in your career location matters and
there is such a thing as creator hot
spots
um and i mean it just kind of makes
sense right if you also were going to
open up any kind of business you want to
be where the traffic is you want to be
where
um there is volume of of maybe customers
or whatever so positioning where your
positioning can matter maybe you can't
change that and i would have never
expected we didn't even intentionally do
this when we moved to vegas first we
were just following god
on an opportunity for a job opening to
work at a church
we never thought we would have lived in
vegas i learned this by accident i just
learned that once i got here i was like
wow i'm in different environments i'm in
a more cluster of leadership and
creativity and momentum and ambition
and it propelled us forward location
just matters and i think this is an
interesting insight that the study
revealed that there's benefits to living
in creator hot spots
creating so on social is essential for
mental well-being hit like if you're
getting value out of this and if you are
enjoying parent life to see john stephen
cannell's little face at the bottom of
the screen here
um this one shocked me really lean in
for this
they discovered
and through this 000
person creator survey
that there is a mental health benefit to
being a content creator
as you're watching this and this new
study reveals why now is the best time
to create content i think i'm going to
take this a different direction than you
expected based on data
that there is a mental health now this
is polarizing information a lot of
people out here right are talking about
the negatives to social media and that
is true but watch what this study
discovered
creators who post most frequently and
spend the most time creating social
content are also the most positive
clinical research has tied social media
use with depression among adults however
in the case of creators who find and
derive pleasure from sharing their work
there is an inverse relationship with
social media the more time you spend
creating and posting social content the
higher the reported positivity
wow
so what do we learn
if we're consuming too much social media
content
just scrolling comparing you know to
others like just getting in that
dopamine loop constantly getting fear of
missing out or just being like my life
my blooper reel doesn't compare to other
people's highlight reel depression's
going up mental health is going down
but
creators
are more positive and have better
mental health what does that teach us
it's surprising
you need to create more than you consume
you need to get in the game and be a
creator not just a consumer
that if you're posting frequently there
is benefits from that the study goes on
the more content creators post and the
more time they spend creating the more
positive they feel especially among
business owners and influencers so let
me ask you have you found this to be
true whether you're struggling to grow
whether you feel like you're just
starting you're not getting the views
yet
but have you found that by creating that
there's a fulfillment and a positivity
and an accomplishment
and that once you punch fear in the face
and you finally press record did you
discover that
you were starting to be more positive
and more happy
because that's what the clinical
research revealed
that
even though social media use causes
depression among results
that
creators who find and derive pleasure
from sharing their work
they actually have an inverse
relationship with social media and
higher reported positivity here's the
key word happiness creating social
content on the daily is just as much a
driver as of happiness is making money
and i love that because i found that to
be true of course we want to join the
creator economy for the money we can
make i'm going to share some stats in
just a second with you about that that's
fascinating
but there's a fulfillment to it there's
a fulfillment to making something
there's a fulfillment to pressing upload
for those of you that are actually
uploading content do you feel that are
you pumped when you're about to make
that video go live are you pumped when
you're about to like schedule upload are
you about to hit go live and be like
all right here we go seven views i mean
i hoped for more than that but but
they're even just doing it there's
something really powerful and for
creators and especially influencers
using or creating social content is even
ranked as a top
necessity for mental health pretty crazy
and so
this increased participation in creating
content is
tied to a more positive mood across all
countries
in the us seventy percent of people have
a more positive mood from creating
content you know in every country
there's a boost in positivity if you are
not
just consuming but you're creating and
so creating social content on the daily
drives just as much happiness as making
money and they discovered this
and among those who earn money like
business owners and influencers posting
daily further boosts positivity for
creators and especially influencers
using or creating social content is even
ranked as a top necessity for mental
health but creating content online
fuels creativity and personal
fulfillment which drives creators to
continue creating so
fulfillment now notice on the right side
of the screen and i know this is small
and i'll link this study up in the
description if you're here live i
haven't linked it up yet but it will be
linked there on the replay
so the top reasons for developing and
creating original social media content
more often 61 percent of people said i
want to continue learning and developing
new skills
so when we think about i know the
headline of this video is like why now
is the best time to start creating
content you might not have thought
oh because i could have more well-being
as a result oh
because i should start creating content
so i can learn and develop new skills
here's another one 54 of people i want
to explore new things and have more
content to share
so my life can get bigger and more
enriched and even more fulfilling and 50
of people said it's fun
and so there's just something about
stepping into the creator economy
because of the many-fold benefits that
nobody talks about and i've never seen a
study actually prove
data about this and so this is kind of
cool and so in just a second i actually
want to share with you
the 10 human drives that i learned in a
book and it's one of my favorite books
and i want to share with you the money
making aspect of this plus i have six
takeaways from all of this but if you'll
be getting value smash the like button
and um
today's coffee with canel is actually
brought to you by 21videotips.com if you
haven't heard about this yet check this
out and i'll be right back if you like
content like this then you definitely
want to go to
21videotips.com where you're going to
get 21 amazing tips from entrepreneurs
like patrickbetdavid vanessa lau pat
flynn and so many more also alex ramoses
in there as well where you're going to
be learning some of their
little-known business secrets and inside
of this resource we're giving you a
downloadable guide that goes along with
it to help you get impact right away so
go to 21videotips.com
right now to get that free resource and
this incredible video that has 21
amazing tips from special guests just
like this
if you haven't got access to it yet go
to 21videotips.com
there's a one hour long deep dive master
class with today's top experts in video
marketing and youtube sharing their best
strategies for getting views and
subscribers there's also a free pdf
download that summarizes all the tips
and this is some of the most bleeding
edge information people actually paid as
much as five thousand dollars for a
ticket to attend this in-person content
business event that we did and we're
giving you away the highlights of that
for free so there's a link in the
description 21 videotips.com highly
recommend you checking it out but here's
what we're learning in this study of
over 9000 content creators from around
the world that adobe adobe is in like
adobe premiere pro adobe photoshop adobe
conducted this research study and one of
the things they discovered was that
creating content leads to more
fulfillment and better mental health now
key not consuming content not just
scrolling all day watching tick tock
constantly and then feeling like what
did i actually accomplish
that's the key maybe not much
but when you create content your
contributing you're making a difference
and there's actually a great book called
the charge by brendon burchard and it
actually talks about the 10 human drives
that make us feel alive
and what i've never talked about this
before but these are so relevant for
content creators and it's so it's
interesting these pieces came together
for me because the study revealed okay
content creators are more positive and
more happy interesting and then i
thought about okay well why is that and
then brendan's research she actually
discovered again from psychology that
there's 10 human drivers that help us
live a more charged life a more
fulfilled life that get out of the caged
life that get out of the comfortable
life and get into a life that is vibrant
that is thriving and those include
things like control
when one of the things you can't control
is how many views you get but what you
can control is how many up videos you
upload
and so when you think about the fact
that being a content creator you start
being in control of making something
you're building your youtube channel
you're building something it gives you
control again you can't control the
results but you can control your outputs
and there's something about the
confidence that you get after you have
hit your fifth upload your 10th upload
competence the confidence competence
loop like you get more competent
as you are learning new skills now you
might be saying sean when i started my
first videos are my worst videos i get
you
but there's something when you start
feeling momentum have you felt this
you're like man i look back on my first
videos they're terrible but i'm a little
better on camera now
i'm a little more confident on camera
wow i've had a breakout video that
competence is a human need to sharpen
our skills to grow congruence being
aligned with our values caring making a
difference in the lives of people
connection i think about all the
friendships relationships and different
things that have happened because i
started creating content more i am more
connected and my life is bigger now
because of joining the creator economy
and then of course change that your
youtube channel can make change
challenge one of my favorites it is
challenging
to start a youtube channel
and if you've been afraid and you've
been on the fence or if you've hesitated
from punching fear in the face and
getting started i want to encourage you
we as humans crave challenge
we crave we sh we need to get out of
being comfortable and get into hard
situations
if you've been creating content and you
feel like man there's pressure around
this this is kind of overwhelming at
times i want to quit at times good
being challenged is healthy we don't
want to be in a culture where we're
afraid of challenge we want to run into
challenge creative expression i mean
that is directly relevant by being a
content creator what better way of
having creative expression contribution
actually adding value teaching something
entertaining somebody and then of course
consciousness
a greater connection to purpose that is
assuming that you actually have a higher
purpose a greater purpose for why you're
creating content online so i just kind
of found this as a little break in our
tour through this study if you want to
check out the book i linked it up in the
description it's called the charge by
brennan burchard the 10 human drives
that make us come alive
i think it's so fascinating now that
data has revealed that content creators
are happier of course that's not
everybody and nothing ever is but but as
across countries they discovered higher
levels of positivity i think this is why
when you get off of the couch and you
get into the game and you start creating
you get challenged
you start having more connection right
you start seeing more change you start
growing incompetence you're expressing
your creativity and then regardless of
the results of course that's going to
give you more momentum as well but
there's something you could be proud of
like i look back at my video library
just for its own merits i'm like man
i've been hustling i've been putting in
the work and i'm proud of the time i've
spent editing and the late nights and of
the things i've learned along the way
and who how i've changed as a human as a
man as a father as a leader how i've
been transformed by just joining the
creator economy
wow
now is the time to start creating
content if you've been on the fence i
encourage you to get into the game now
here's some more from the study more
than 40 of creators globally are
millennials
and they skew slightly mail at 52
on average creators are 40 years old
this is fascinating and this is a huge
myth people think that all creators
are
gen z
and gen z only really represents 14 of
creators so let me let me if you're if
you want to be so bold where are you at
on the journey i'm coming up november
6th i'm turning
um
39
and uh so i'm about to be one of those
40 year old you know creators uh not a
40 year old virgin
weird thing to say but it's true i mean
i literally have a baby boy here on my
uh you know in my front pack and so
if you know how those
get made then you would know that
anyways i'm on my way to 40 and uh
and so i think that one of the things
that surprises people is that
millennials
is what this discovers is the largest
group so where are you you could say
your generation right i know also
millennials are broken into millennials
elder millennials
um gen gen z
gen x is a huge group of content
creators and even baby boomers are
joining as content creators right now
and so surprising that's what the data
is showing us
um and then it also just revealed that
brazil france us and uk have the highest
concentration of gen z craters
and south korea and australia have the
fewest now six and ten creators have
full-time jobs but markets like
australia brazil and japan have a higher
share of creators who work part-time so
if you're in the side hustle season
respect
you're you're in good company so six and
ten creators have
full-time jobs
so
and what's interesting is a lot of these
creators which they surveyed are making
money but it's a side hustle thing
so you're in good company if you're like
man why am i not full time yet well
there's a lot of people that are
creating they have as a content creator
and they also have a full-time job so if
you also feel that squeeze there know
that globally you're in good company and
even in some of the other countries
there's even more people that are kind
of doing the part-time thing and there's
a lot of respect for that and it's just
it's super normal like that's one of the
most exciting things i think about the
crater economy is of course maybe your
ambition i'm sure is to completely work
from home full-time have total freedom
however on the journey it's incredibly
normal to also have a full-time job
but then also have this side hustle side
passion that as it grows starts bringing
in extra money for you your family
and so i found this very in this study
now 26 percent of creators in the us are
business owners
and this translates to 22 million
business owners in the u.s
and
i love this because that's some of our
favorite uh kind of perspective in fact
i'll keep it moving
this i think that
we should think more like business
owners and less like influencers and
creators
now here's some interesting things about
posting frequency
uh years of content experience for a
creator now if you're just joining
earlier we kind of defined the
difference between creator and
influencer for this study like everyone
probably has their own definition but
this study kind of figured that out but
for creators uh 52 have under two years
of experience but 48 have three plus
years of experience i'm curious how long
have you been creating content
influencers they define a little bit
differently
they uh more have had three plus years
of experiences then they talked about
posting frequency
monthly or less 32 percent of creators
week at least weekly 68 of creators and
that's what you hear right
post at least once a week i'm curious
what is your posting frequency
daily 21
and then it says time spent per week on
content development 9 hours per week for
the creator and 15 hours a week for the
influencer
and in to recap a little bit of their
definition the creator is somebody who's
doing something else like they're a
photographer business and they're
creating content to help grow their
business and get more wedding clients
that they're filming they're a cupcake
brick and mortar shop and they're
creating content to promote their shop
so it also makes sense why they'd be
spending less time per week because you
have other things to do the blessing of
being an influencer which their
definition is someone who just makes
their full-time living purely off
content creation itself so if you're
making enough money off just doing
youtube ads
just patreon just channel memberships
even just brand deals it's just
potentially content and it's not i have
literally a real estate business to own
and i need to make content on top of
that so how much time are you devoting
to your content creation right now per
week
um are you spending 10 hours a week on
your you know youtube channel
are you spending more than that less
than that i'm kind of curious um i know
for me
i
right before i went full time on youtube
for actually about a year i had
freelance clients uh three main
freelance clients
and i served them and was doing youtube
content but before that i was full-time
at a church
as a campus pastor and kind of doing
tech and media and i was working about
40 45 hours
a week of course for the church salary
full-time
and then i was probably investing
another 15 hours a week in my content
creation business alan says you know 15
hours a week ivan says i take as much
time as i can
um
and let's see black trunks podcast says
i've been doing two to three hour live
streams every day for 22 days that's a
lot of hustle right there um and so
i'm curious you know let me know and
we're gonna keep it moving so
here we go the average hourly wage now
i'm curious what you think about this
and do you agree with this is this
challenge you're thinking your
experience
um now i will of course link to this
study so you can see the methodology
this was 9000 content creators and the
ones that
the data is pulled from here
are monetized
so
for the amount of time they're working
per week keep this in mind
they are
maybe six out of ten have a part-time
job or they have another job
but here's the conclusion of the study
that creators make 61 dollars per hour
122 000 annually if if if that was
mapped to full-time and influencers are
making 81 dollars per hour 162 000
annually if done time
and what was i love this because this
compared was comparable to professional
income uh they compared this to being a
software engineer apparently the average
salary of a software engineer is 160 000
a year the average salary of a lawyer is
129 000 a year this is all based in the
usd
cpa 119 000 a year
so if you map
assuming and it's a big assumption that
you can make full-time income you
actually would earn that much and you
could do that 40 hours a week full time
that's going to map out you know 50
weeks a year probably two weeks vacation
122 000 a year as a content creator and
so pretty pretty interesting data i
don't know that's what the study
revealed again they said a 9 000 global
content creators that were monetized and
here's the takeaway
is
um you need to know that this is
lucrative i want to be empathetic you're
listening to this you're like dude that
is not my experience i'm making like a
dollar an hour okay fair enough
but i will say we have a unique vantage
point um you know think media
obviously
i think you could equate our entire team
as to working in the crater economy so
there's the money they're making we're
doing well um i think about our students
mary nicole dr ihealth a lot of our
students they're making high five
figures six figures many are making
seven figures it's a lucrative industry
empathetically it does i'm not saying it
doesn't take hustle and i'm also not
saying it doesn't take potentially a
year two three four to build up to
momentum and real impact but there is a
tipping point and i just want to
encourage you there is real money to be
made in the creator economy
so while influencers in the uk earn the
most per hour
that's cool any uk creators out there
more influencers in the us and germany
indicate income is half or more of their
monthly income
so to also be clear and if you look on
screen you can see it says how much the
hourly rate
of creators versus influencers
influencers full-time making money from
just their content creators making money
maybe from booking clients
selling their own product or doing
something else
influencers making a little bit more
than than creators
per hour across u.s uk france germany
but it's also saying that this is
you know half
or more than their monthly income so the
idea is that it hasn't gone to a place
where it can replace the job
eventually the time you're investing in
creating content
and the 10 hours a week you do so can be
very lucrative
but maybe there's a lid to that and you
can't go full time i don't know if i'm
processing this well but this is just
very interesting yep shout out to the uk
crew and uh this is just cool data of
what's happening in the crater economy
now
uh rather than aspiring to be an
influencer about 40 of creators aspire
to become a business owner this is one
of my favorite parts of this study
is that people's desire
oh hey hey john stephen this might be
the end of our stream
people's desire
is to uh
is to actually be
a business owner right not just a
creator and this is what we're trying to
encourage you to do here at think media
podcast world
you you should think about man what is
the business i'm starting what is the
problem i solve
what is the
you know who are my target audience who
are my ideal customers well sean i just
want views well your viewers are
an audience that's watching your content
and if you're making money from ads you
essentially have customers like a
movie's not going to succeed if nobody
buys tickets people even need to vote
with their time when watching your
content and so the aspiration
this is just encouraging that most want
to be business owners and i think you're
going to have the most success in your
career
if you aspire to be a business owner
what's the business i'm starting and
then how am i using social media youtube
tick tock to promote that
business and so globally creators are
becoming more interested in becoming
business owners than influencers and
then also creators across the board
agree that creating online content has a
big impact on advancing causes
especially influencers and social cause
creators and there is data revealing
that
social media can make a real difference
we've seen it you know topple
governments we've seen it liberate
people groups we've seen the positives
of social media they probably don't get
talked about as much because there are
certainly downsides to social media but
if you have a desire to make a
difference in the world and to make a
difference in the lives of people now is
the greatest time to join the creator
economy so i'm going to check in with my
son here and see how much longer he's
got
uh but um
i wanna share with you six of my
takeaways and tips for you we'll see if
we can get through them all and so smash
like have you been getting value out of
this information and i'll be right back
if you like content like this then you
definitely want to go to
21videotips.com where you're going to
get 21 amazing tips from entrepreneurs
like patrickbetdavid vanessa lau pat
flynn and so many more also alex or
moses in there as well where you're
going to be learning some of their
little known business secrets and inside
of this resource we're giving you a
downloadable guide that goes along with
it to help you get impact right away so
go to 21videotips.com
right now to get that free resource and
this incredible video that has 21
amazing tips from special guests just
like this
welcome back to coffee with kennel my
name is sean cannell rhymes with youtube
channel and i've been doing this entire
stream with my newborn one week old son
john stephen cannell and so i got the
binky in his mouth let me see if i can
go through these six tips for you these
are my biggest takeaways and then check
out links and resources in the
description down below uh here's your
here's your takeaways number one
competition is rising but so
is consumption and so right now uh i
think there's a massive opportunity yes
165 million content creators joined in
the last two years but competition is up
number two embrace the side hustle i
think there's something powerful about
knowing that a lot of creators are
working part-time and it can still be
lucrative it could still be a good way
to supplement your income so now is a
really good time to start three there's
real money to be made keep going don't
quit there is real money to be made in
the crater economy it is a legitimized
way of earning money and making um
income four consume less create more
surprising
creating content helps your mental
health globally they discover there's
more positivity listen not when you're
scrolling constantly on social media but
when you're actually creating content
and remember the 10 human drives that
make you come alive those are really
activated when you join the crater
economy punch fear in the face and
actually press record number five don't
be an influencer start a business
instead
so this study even revealed that it's so
important i think to be thinking about
like jay-z said i'm not a businessman i
am a business man
it's a different way of thinking it's an
entire mindset shift and if you haven't
been listening to our think media
podcast we have new episodes every
two weeks or i mean every tuesday it
comes out every week we're going to like
probably two three uploads a week so i
highly recommend a lot of valuable
content there but subscribe on here on
youtube but also on spotify or apple
podcast wherever you listen
we have some really good episodes kind
of helping you develop the business mind
as well as
really develop your creator business
that's how we're thinking we're not just
thinking be an influencer no disrespect
to in the influencer lifestyle i just
think that you're gonna have the most
longevity the most health the most
sustainability the most you're not gonna
have 15 minutes of fame you can actually
make a bigger impact and a real impact
when you're not just an influencer but
you start a business instead and use
content
use youtube to promote that bigger
vision to promote your own products and
services event eventually and to
ultimately promote your vision and
mission which brings us to number six
use social media to change the world
what the study revealed is social media
can make a real difference and you know
we're on a mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with youtube
and online video this is real friends
you can teach you can entertain you can
create community you can be somebody
that literally reaches into somebody
else's life through a live stream
through a youtube video through a
youtube short through an instagram reel
and actually bring encouragement bring
education this whole thing is real and i
think that's why so many people are
joining the creator economy why so much
money is flowing into the crater economy
because social media and youtube
can make real change in the world and
you're going to be blown away by the
level of energy and inspiration and
motivation and vision and purpose that
is unlocked
when you really lean in
to creating
content my name is sean cannell and i
would love to do q a typically but uh as
you can see
i had a moment that i thought i thought
i was gonna lose him uh but this is uh
my son john stephen cannell what look at
that shot right there what do you know
about this little guy and uh he is
officially a week old right now mom's
taking a nap
and i just want you to know i appreciate
you i'm thankful for you i may have just
disturbed the young gun um and so thanks
for hanging out with me today and i look
forward to seeing you in a future
episode here on our think media podcast
channel we will talk soon